So what the partial or the planner has done so
far is to view the two goals as if they were independent of each other.
And come up with a partial plan for each of the two goals. It has not yet
detected any conflicts between that will not resolve those conflicts.
The next thing would be to examine the relationship between these two plans and
see if there are any conflicts between. But how might a partial order plan
go about detecting conflicts between two plans? So, here is plan one imagined,
here is plan two. The partial order planner may go about detecting conflicts.
We're look at each precondition of the current plan. Under the precondition of
an operator any current plan is clobbered by some state in the,
another plan, in the second plan, than the partial order planner would know that
there's a conflict between them. [UNKNOWN] goal resolving these conflicts, but
promoting or demoting one clients goal or another clients goal.
There's if some stated plan B covers the application of some operator in plan A,
then we now want to alter the goals in this plan and this plan in
such a way that this operator's done before that state is achieved. Now,
let us see how the partial order planner may go about detecting conflicts within
these two plans. So the partial order planner may begin with this plan for
painting the ladder. And see whether the precondition of this operator,
paint-ladder, are clobbered by any state in the second plan. As it turns out,
that doesn't happen in this example. Now, the partial order planner will look at
the operands in the second plan. And see whether the preconditions of any of
the operators are clobbered by some status in this first plan. So
let's look at climb-ladder here. The precondition of climb-ladder is, on robot,
floor, and dry ladder. And as this precondition is compared with the states.
In the first plan, we can eventually see the conflict. Here is dry ladder, and
here is not dry ladder. And this way the partial order planner has been able to
find that the water-less states here in the first plan proverbs the precondition
of one operator on this second plan. To resolve this conflict, the partial order
planner may promote these goals or the goal of painting the ladder.
Some of you also noticed that after the robot has painted the ceiling,
the robot is on ladder. But in order to apply the paint ladder operator,
the robot must be on the floor. So here there is an open condition problem.
This particular condition where this operator is not being satisfied.
When the robot is on the ladder. We'll come to this in a minute.